I am living for trailer dog right now
yeah trailer targets the hit of the
spring you know it's the biggest debut
in in fake television history these
comments on it she's like I feel like
you're just having the voice people on
yeah so far but we're gonna shake things
up I promise we will yes I'm still
trying to get Adam to do it we'll see no
nothing with Adam yet who's your dream
trailer talk guests I don't know we're
gonna come up with something you guys
let me know who you want
John let him know one other thing that I
have to ask you that is not the voice
related is Game of Thrones related I
know you're huge fan right I like the
show yes I'm not I am NOT a serious
serious Game of Thrones fan I'm like I
watch it just to stay abreast of what
everybody else is doing but it's not
like I'm not as into it as like the
people I see tweeting about it yeah well
I thought you were gonna have like a
hard time letting go of the show are you
are you planning anything for the end of
this era not really I'll be fine I have
friends that are super into it and I
watch it just to be like aware of what
the rest of the world is excited about
but I don't know I'm not that passionate
about it truly well I was given
misinformation that I apologize oh you
know why was because we had one of our
good friends over and his wife doesn't
watch it and Chrissy doesn't watch it so
they were out watching one thing and
then I was in there in the theater
watching it with him and they thought
it'd be funny to disrupt our viewing and
so it was a whole thing we had fun with
it but bottom line is I like the show
I'm not super passionate about it though
truly it's not a criticism I was just
nice is not it doesn't hit me to my core
well I was just talking to Kelly about
her episode of trailer talk and the
parent language that is so evident
between the two of you she was telling
me that she wants her son to marry Luna
did you know that oh she's she's told me
something like that before
yeah Lunas pretty cute I had my own baby
Luna was like my favorite
that's your little girl though are you a
little like don't marry my girl off yet
well you know all in due time but you
know I'm not one of those parents that
thinks you have to lock your girls up
you know they're gonna experience life
and they'll date when it's time and you
know I wish her the best and I hope she
finds a good man now the fans had a lot
of opinions about the cross battles they
want to know what you honestly think
about it if you want to see it come back
into the competition again you know I
have heard from the other coaches
because I haven't seen you know I
haven't personally experienced what it
was like before even though I I knew the
show was different and had a different
format before I think the other coaches
didn't like it because they wanted more
control over narrowing the team down
before we let the fans vote and I could
see the wisdom in that before I let you
go Mother's Day coming up this week what
do you have planned well we've got some
great gifts it's become an annual
tradition now I do a yearbook like a
photo book for a Crissy of the family
and all the things we did that year
leading into Mother's Day no we do like
it's we make it like a coffee table book
like it's fashion or something and you
know the first time I did one of those
was for our wedding did a really
beautiful you know coffee table book of
our wedding and then I've been doing it
since Luna was born and then we do it as
like a Mother's Day tradition now yeah
[Applause]
[Music]